this week's 48 hours investigates the
killing of a top-ranked ufc
fighter's step-daughter after her
disappearance in 2019.
college student anaya blanchard was last
seen at an alabama gas station and her
alleged killer
was a man with a long arrest record out
on bond
now her parents who had to wait weeks to
learn anaya's fate
are fighting for justice cbs news
special correspondent james brown spoke
with the family
these are the last images of anaya
blanchard
at a gas station in auburn near her
apartment
just the worst feeling ever anaya's
mother
angela harris and her stepfather
ufc fighter walt harris were frantic
we drove my truck in backwoods
we were all in people's yards anaya's
car
which was badly damaged was found 55
miles away
investigators say a blood soaked
passenger seat
and a bullet hole in the door tell the
story of what happened to anaya that
night
so traumatizing to think about what she
went through
authorities believe anaya ran into
ibrahim yazid
when she stopped at the gas station
yazid is a man with a
lengthy arrest record and he had been
charged earlier that year
with robbing and beating two people in
spite of those serious charges
yazid was free on bond anaya's college
roommate
sarah o'brien how is this person
free to walk into a gas station how is
he in the same gas station as my best
friend
but yazid maintains his innocence
the harrises were committed to facing
yazid
whenever he appeared in court you see
him
mr yazid looking back at you guys walt
i remember shaking i wanted to climb
across
the barricade it took all of walt's
training in the ring
and angela's steady hand to keep him
from ripping into yazid she grabbed me
and she said
just breathe and i just started trying
to hear her voice
angela how did you stay composed
i wanted him to know that i'm
representing my daughter
you don't scare me and that i'm not
going anywhere
we're right here and we're going to
represent our daughter and we're going
to fight
wow james brown joins us now jb good
morning we're all here wondering how
yazid was even out and in that gas
station at that time uh
what actions are the harris family uh
taking now
co-tailing on that very question there
tony right now there's broad political
and legislative support for anaya's law
which mom angela a feisty and tough
woman indeed has been fighting for
it has passed the state house it goes
down to the senate and if it does
then it'll go to a public vote to keep
violent offenders
off the streets you know this is the
kind of thing that rips through a family
and
rips through people's lives how will it
affect the career of walt harris you
think
you know you use the words rip through
and that's exactly what's happening tony
we can only imagine what the family is
feeling and
walt instantly quit fighting of course
once that tragedy took place
but there were two things that happened
one he knew that anaya
was his biggest fan and two he recently
had a dream where she hugged him
and she encouraged him to get back in
the ring which he did recently and
apparently is going to continue his
career
but you can only imagine what's
happening internally with that
especially
in a tough sport like ufc fighting
getting in an
octagon that is not for the faint of
heart toning
you can say that again jb thank you very
much and you can see jb's full report
fighting for anaya on 48 hours tomorrow
at 10
9 central right here on cbs i still
remember that story and i think it must
be so haunting for the family to see the
last video of her
in the store where she meets the man who
ultimately took her life
it's heartbreaking to see for walt to
sit there in the courtroom though and be
still
knowing what happened we're thinking
about them